l'environnement c'est devenu le sujet
incontournable alors carole gélinas eux
demandent un demi million de personnes
ont marché à montréal pour
l'environnement mais des milliers
d'affichés faite de plastique coroplast
paul une rue ce qu'on ne peut pas faire
campagne autrement en 2019
bonne question que beaucoup de gens se
posent depuis des années c'est
complètement écologique de faire des
affiches si pollution il y as pour cet
expert est les visuels et le marketing
politique ne peut se passer des fameuses
pancartes
il s'adresse surtout à ceux qui n'ont
pas tous les outils pour s'intéresser à
la campagne faut comprendre qu'il ya
quand même 50 % de la population que les
problèmes de lecture de l'itération le
fait de voir une couleur d'un parti avec
un visage avec un nom le dédier essor où
les gens c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'associer à moi je sais donc juridique
terry karting lorsque je vais aller dans
le mur
je vais pouvoir retrouver le même nom ça
c'est pour le côté utilité démocratique
mais le plastique coroplast face aux
cycles bien c'est un produit qui a
travaillé fort dans sa vie autre que est
accroché sur un poteau ce qui fait que
le produit qui arrive chez nous est en
excellente condition et on peut le
transformer en faire quelque chose de
vraiment intéressant
la preuve avec leur vidéo d'entreprise
[Musique]
partie des planches de plastique on a
différents volets on un volet
construction on est volé mobilier urbain
dont étape des chaises on ne dit pas
parc des poubelles des paniers revue de
recyclage aussi dans cette usine
seulement entre 10 et 20 tonnes de
plants câbles sont transformées chaque
année les entreprises comme replace
peuvent payer 200 à 250 dollars la tonne
pour des pancartes leurs auteurs la loi
électorale oblige à enlever les affiches
quinze jours après les élections les
partis peuvent contacter directement
cette entreprise